hi I'm Rachel Brosnahan and I'm
Michael's Egon we are here at BuzzFeed
to play with puppy and answer your
questions
we'll try we're gonna have to answer is
there a role that people would be
surprised to hear you auditioned for but
didn't book I auditioned for the last
airbender movie when I was like 16 or 17
I didn't audition for it cuz I was like
I'm not I I think my agent had called
and said that they got this audition for
me and I was like no I'm not
and it was fifty Shades of Grey I was
like you I believe but me like no no no
we collaborate why was that
what no I mean you know well I'm just
wrong for that
so no get out of my question jar which
of your cast mates is most like their
Mazal character in real life Alex
Borstein pretty sure that like Suzy she
has a squishy interior I think she okay
Michael's vegan he's gonna adopt a puppy
today well we'll see how it goes and I'm
gonna end up with 12 in my house who has
made you the most starstruck
I love Teen Wolf growing up the movie
team with Michael J Fox and I I met him
once and that was incredibly I was
incredibly starstruck by Michael J Fox
as one would be but I also auditioned
for a TV show once and the director was
the guy who played Stiles I like I lost
like I couldn't say any of the lines
like I was so starstruck this is a long
time ago but I was so starstruck just
like by auditioning in front of Stiles
probably um Stevens oh yeah yeah sure
really him and Stiles you and Dan we and
we met Steven Spielberg at the Golden
Globes the first time we went and
and I don't know that I was expecting to
be as starstruck as I was but I grew up
watching Steven Spielberg movies and and
seeing him in person I just felt like I
was so overwhelmed yeah what's your
favorite episode of marvelous mrs. Mazal
so far I like all the Catskills
that's the catechol they are really
special and it's um nostalgic for like a
year ago when we filmed there it was
really fun yeah we thought it was wet I
also love I love I think it's episode 5
of last season also in the Catskills
when ABC's mid to do stand-up our first
time I feel like we've been building to
that moment since the beginning of the
show and it did not disappoint and I
love a season finale last year - I did -
yeah it's so really good it was the
telethon I mean there's some every
episode is my favorite who is your
funniest Mazal cast mate so many to
choose from
there really are Alex Alex Tony Caroline
Aaron Kevin Kevin Pollak one of my
favorite things about Tony is have you
ever shot a scene that Tony Laden yeah
he gets cranky no not crazy oh well he's
he gets like slap-happy and he knows
he's cranky in the morning nah he's a
little cranky in the morning do your
best impressions of each other no I
can't do an impression of you but one of
my favorite things that you have done as
Joel is when you get all like Rico suave
you know you like you have this slash me
and use me this you're right so here let
me do it you guys yeah what can you
tease about season three I think it's no
secret that were on the road a little
bit this season
sterling K Brown has joined the cat she
does some stand-up I do the the
audience's keep getting bigger and
bigger
for Mitch's stand-up we're gonna put all
of these guys on the show are you team
Benjamin team Joel or team neither for
Mitch I don't know I don't know I mean
like yes I'm team Joel for obvious
reasons but I I thought you and Benjamin
had
some good chemistry so do you think the
mid Jindal should end up together maybe
someday but not right now I think right
now he needs to let her do her thing
hey great but I really I really love how
their relationship has evolved yeah ya
know for sure there's a lot of Benjamin
stands I have been getting abused on the
Instagram about Zach not being in the
cast photo no but the whole cast wasn't
in the photo
that doesn't mean anything one way or
another is there a comedian from today
that you'd like to have on your show Ali
Wong Ali Wong I love her oh gosh she's
so good I watched a lot of Ali Wong and
prep for the show baby Cobra was I felt
like it was sort of in a similar not the
same but in a similar style I feel like
Ali and Midge have a very similar sense
of humor I would love to have her on the
show but I like Billy Eichner I think
he's I don't know he does stand up for
anything but him or Steve Martin would
be cool yes
what were your first impressions of each
other we've known each other a long time
yeah I'm scared don't answer that
no my first impression was I was like
this girl is amazing because we met we
did a play movie a script reading
together when you were like 19 19 yeah I
was like damn this is a good actor right
here that was my first impression I felt
the same and we had a lot of friends in
common I felt like you were kind of
doing what I really wanted to do you
know in the theater world in New York
and and like alternating between theater
and and film and TV and really really
great actor well it was nice that we met
each other acting that reason yeah that
was nice when we got to chem read for
this that we knew each other all oh yeah
that helped immensely and I said this in
an interview recently when when we
rehearsed went before I went in to test
with you yeah and we were able to
rehearse in that little room I was like
I got this I thought the theme yeah to
be honest yeah I knew the minute we
started reading care about you it was
gonna be you what shows you binge
watching right now I just finished
fleabag
season two that was good Barry Barry
Barry is one of my favorite things on TV
right now I just watch the final season
of leap which I also love so good with
me what has been your favorite costume
that you've worn on the show
I like when Joel's not in business mode
I like where he's like he's in like yeah
letting loose Joel and I like his ties
because all the ties are usually vintage
and I think mm-hmm yeah and they give me
a few to choose from and I like them
this I will say that Donna decals our
cross stream designer keeps out giving
herself every time I go into a costume
fitting it's like the new best day of my
life except for this nothing whatever
talk to it what's your go-to deli order
I like matzo ball soup thank you and
pastrami or corned beef on what I'm Ron
right yeah and pickles I like pickles
pickles are so good I like Turkey and
coleslaw yeah that's good sandwich tell
the truth do you think there's any
chance Joel could have made it as a
comic with Mitch no what with Mitch like
as a duo no he's not funny
he's kind of funny but not as funny he's
not funny
he's a plagiarize ER he's stealing other
people's jokes Rachael can your dogs
please make a cameo on the show I would
love that
I think Shiba inus not so 1950s but
every family had a pitbull in the 1950s
Nicki is primed and ready she's waiting
for her starter and the more people can
you tell a story of when you really you
really capitalize ya realize just how
huge the show was so I was in Times
Square and you know there was that oh
come on guys break it up kid come sit on
my lap and these these guys don't want
to have anything to do with me so I was
in Times Square and this was a guest
back in like December and I was taking a
picture of myself in front of in front
of the big billboard of yourself
- come on you know and this girl stopped
me and she's like is that you and I was
like yeah she's like I'm from India and
your show is huge in India oh I so I
asked her I was like well why why why is
this so big in India and she said she
thinks that cuz like the family aspect
of the show that was that was pretty
that was pretty big um I had a moment
like that recently actually I don't know
I don't know that there's one moment I
can point to but there's been quite a
few um we're like really lovely and
interesting and some weird moments but I
had him home the other day where I was
seeing a play and this girl in the
theatre just went are you Rachel
Brosnahan and I thought like because we
knew someone in common or something that
happened she goes I'm from Mexico and
I'm just in town for like two days and I
I don't know why that really blew my
mind she said my name right - and last
but not least what's your dream role
fresh I would like to play Garko Groucho
Marx oh man that's a really good one no
I'd like it I'd really love to play
Carson McCullers okay that one's been on
my list for a while now I love I love
Carson McCullers Souza and she's so
interesting and had such a fascinating
and kind of sad but really rich life and
I'd love to play her what do you think
what do you think all of these adorable
puppies are available for adoption
through North Shore Animal League
America and you better adopt them before
I save him you can catch the marvelous
mrs. mazelon Amazon Prime we're working
away on season 3 thanks for watching and
bye
[Music]